À chaque rencontre, nous leur servions à manger, jour après jour.
Nous devions nous développer.
On a donc déménagé dans un grand stade.
De 25 000 repas, on est passé à 50 000.
D'un seul coup, nous sommes devenus le plus grand restaurant du monde.
On préparait près de 70 000 repas par jour dans un seul endroit.
(Applaudissements)
Les bénévoles sont venus par centaines.
À un certain moment, il y avait plus de 7 000 bénévoles
qui travaillaient avec nous pour une heure au moins,
et à tout moment, ils étaient plus de 700.
Vous voyez, on a créé un mouvement,
un mouvement basé sur une idée simple à laquelle tout le monde peut se rallier :
nourrissons ceux qui ont faim.
En cuisinant des plats que les gens pouvaient reconnaître,
pas un machin venu d'un endroit lointain
emballé dans du plastique et qui ne sent rien.
(Rires)
Nous cuisinions des repas qui rappellaient la maison.
Dans ces moments-là, les gens ressentent le besoin urgent de se sentir en vie,
de savoir que quelqu'un se soucie d'eux.
Un repas après l'autre,
il s'agissait moins d'apport calorique indispensable pour le corps,
que d'une chose plus cruciale pour eux.
Ils avaient besoin de savoir que vous, vous, vous, et vous,
que vous vous souciez d'eux,
que nous leur transmettions le message que nous étions avec eux.
Donnez-nous du temps, on essaie de réparer tout ça.
Tel était le message que nous découvrions en rejoignant une communauté.
Les fruits frais ont commencé à arriver,
et même FEMA me demandait :
« José, comment fais-tu pour obtenir tous ces aliments ?
- C'est simple : je téléphone, je paye et on me les livre. »
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
On a commencé par San Juan.
En moins de temps qu'il ne faut pour le dire,
on nourrissait 78 municipalités sur l'île.
Un plan était nécessaire.
Une seule cuisine ne peut pas nourrir toute l'île.
Je suis allé voir FEMA, mais huit gardes m'ont repoussé avec leurs armes.
Je leur ai dit que j'avais besoin de 18 cuisines sur l'île.
Devinez ! Il y a trois jours, nous avons ouvert la 18ème cuisine
aux alentours de Porto Rico.
(Applaudissements)
Les gens ont enfin pu manger.
Les bénévoles ont continué d'affluer.
On me disait que nous n'avions pas de système de livraison.
Bien sûr que si, nous avions un système.
L'île entière de Porto Rico était le système de livraison parfait.
Quiconque ayant un camion voulait aider.
Quiconque se rendant de A à B nous permettait d'apporter de l'espoir,
une assiette et un vrai repas à quelqu'un.
On a développé des systèmes incroyables pour les camions-cantines.
10 camions-cantines extraordinaires.
Nous avons appris à ne plus utiliser les noms de lieux nécessitant des repas,
mais les numéros,
les numéros des appartements :
Lolo, un ancien combattant de 92 ans, encerclé par l'eau.
Nous ne faisions pas qu'offrir de l'espoir aux gens,
nous connaissions leur nom,
établissant un contact au quotidien,
pour nous assurer que les plus âgés ne se sentaient plus seuls
dans un moment de désespoir.
Nous avons commencé à aller de plus en plus loin,
des endroits où, soudainement, tous les ponts étaient détruits.
Mais nous devions y aller ; il était trop facile de rester à San Juan.
Nous devions atteindre les zones qui nécessitaient le plus notre aide.
Alors, on a persévéré, et les gens nous attendaient
car ils savaient que nous viendrions,
que nous ne les abandonnerions jamais.
(Applaudissements)
Nos camions-cantines sont devenus nos anges
et ils offraient sans cesse de l'espoir.
Mais c'était évident : nous devions faire plus.
Vieques et Culebra, deux îles éloignées,
avaient besoin qu'on les nourrisse.
On a fait plus qu'apporter des vivres, installer une cuisine à Vieques
et apporter des repas chaque jour à Culebra.
Nous avons aussi apporté le premier système de purification d'eau
dans l'île de Vieques,
où nous ne pouvions filtrer que quatre litres à la minute.
Soudain, des problèmes épineux devenaient très simples,
avec des solutions faciles.
Simplement, en agissant, sans planifier, et sans réunion dans de grands immeubles.
(Rires)
Nous avons trouvé des moyens créatifs.
Besoin d'hélicoptères ? Il n'y a qu'à demander, c'est là.
Besoin d'avions ? Il n'y a qu'à demander, payer, c'est là.
Sans relâche, nous avons livré des aliments là où c'était nécessaire.
Cette idée simple est devenue puissante.
Les bénévoles se rendaient dans les îles.
Soudain, c'était un mouvement.
Les équipes de la cuisine industrielle
étaient accueillies par des prières, des chansons, des applaudissements,
des câlins, des sourires.
Nous avons créé des contacts dans tant d'endroits.
Même la garde nationale nous a appelés à l'aide
car même nos pauvres gardes de la garde nationale,
les héros dans le chaos,
ne trouvaient pas un simple repas chaud pour se nourrir.
Ensuite, des partenariats se sont mis en place : Mercy Corps,
HSI de la Sécurité nationale.
Ces partenariats n'ont pas eu besoin de réunions au sommet.
Ils se sont mis en place dans un hôtel, au milieu d'une rue,
au fin fond de la montagne.
C'était évident : en travaillant ensemble, nous pouvions atteindre plus de personnes.
Des partenariats qui se nouent logiquement,
et l'urgence de l'instant présent est mise au service des gens.
Quand on est une organisation humanitaire d'urgence,
on ne peut pas planifier de l'aide à fournir dans un mois.
Il faut être prêt à offrir son aide
à la seconde même où une catastrophe survient.
On a nourri les enfants,
et soudain, sur toute l'île,
encore fragile dans ce moment bien particulier,
nous avons vu une ONG comme la nôtre --
nous ne voulions pas être en concurrence avec le secteur privé --
des petits restaurants ont commencé à ouvrir,
une certaine normalité,
enfin, ce que « normalité » peut signifier aujourd'hui à Porto Rico, est revenue.
Alors on a commencé à envoyer le message :
Il est temps de quitter les lieux qui sont déjà stabilisés
et de nous concentrer sur les zones qui ont toujours besoin d'aide.
(Vidéo) : Citoyens de Porto Rico, deux millions de repas !
José Andrès : Bon. Je vous traduis ça.
(Rires)
28 jours plus tard,
10 camions-cantines,
plus de 7 000 bénévoles,
18 cuisines...
Nous avions servi plus de deux millions de repas.
(Applaudissements)
Vous ici, à TED, vous pouvez être fiers
car nous savons que beaucoup d'entre vous font partie du changement.
Mais le changement ne survient que si, après avoir quitté cette conférence,
nous mettons au service de ceux qui en ont besoin
ces idées incroyables, ces sources d'inspiration,
et que nous croyons que rien n'est impossible.
J'ai débarqué sur une île pour essayer de nourrir les gens.
J'ai vu un gros problème.
Soudain, les citoyens de Porto Rico ont constaté le même problème que moi,
et nous avons fait une seule chose :
nous avons cuisiné.
Les citoyens de Porto Rico,
et les chefs de Porto Rico, dans ces moments de désespoir,
ont apporté de l'espoir.
Non pas en faisant des réunions,
non pas en planifiant,
mais avec une idée simple :
Cuisinons et nourrissons les gens de Porto Rico.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)
Dave Troy : Reviens !
(Rires)
DT : Le public t'adore.
(Applaudissements)
Nate Mook : Quelques questions rapides,
que j'imagine, beaucoup ici aimeraient poser.
Donc, tu as expliqué qu'à ton arrivée sur place,
tu es allé au centre de commandement du gouvernement,
et que tu as rencontré des gens,
mais qu'ils n'étaient pas très réceptifs.
José Andrés : Super. Ma présentation a été vraiment bonne !
(Rires)
C'est la première présentation avec un follow-up chez TED.
Ça me fait super plaisir.
(Rires)
NM : Dis-nous, quels ont été les défis,
et quand vous êtes-vous aperçus qu'ils venaient vous demander conseil ?
JA : On ne peut pas tout attendre de la Croix Rouge et de l'Armée du Salut.
L'idée, c'est que, et j'ai fait des dons à ces organisations dans le passé,
ce sont de très grandes organisations,
mais le problème est le suivant : nous attendons trop de leur part.
Ce n'est pas qu'elles ne réalisent pas ce qu'elles sont supposées faire.
C'est la perception que nous avons de ce qu'elles font.
Mais dans un moment pareil, on ne peut pas juste s'en laver les mains
et penser que quelqu'un d'autre va s'occuper de la situation.
Le problème était simple et la solution aussi.
On ne parle pas d'un pays éloigné
ou de la zone verte de Bagdad.
On parle des États-Unis,
un lieu magnifique appelé Porto Rico,
avec des centaines et des milliers de restaurants et de gens prêts à aider.
Mais du jour au lendemain, les gens ont eu faim,
et il n'y avait pas de plan en place pour les nourrir à court terme.
FEMA réfléchissait, en quelque sorte, à une façon de nourrir les gens.
La Croix Rouge n'avait pas les réponses,
parce qu'on n'a jamais demandé l'aide de l'Église Baptiste du Sud à Porto Rico,
la plus grande banque alimentaire en Amérique, et mes héros à moi.
Vous voyez, quand la Croix Rouge livre des aliments après un ouragan en Amérique,
c'est l'Église Baptiste du Sud qui le fait.
Mais ils n'étaient pas à Porto Rico.
L'Armée du Salut est venue nous demander 420 repas un mercredi soir pluvieux,
pour un centre de personnes âgées des environs.
J'aide l'Armée du Salut avec plaisir,
mais dans mon monde, c'est elle qui est censée nous aider
à répondre aux appels à l'aide.
Jeudi matin, je me suis réveillé très inquiet
parce que nous n'avions aucun plan pour nourrir l'île.
Certains diront sans doute que nous exagérions le problème.
Mais avec des centaines et des centaines d'organisations
qui venaient frapper à notre porte pour demander des repas,
force est de constater que ce besoin était réel.
On ne peut plus nourrir des gens en Amérique avec des portions lyophilisées
ou des choses qu'on ouvre.
Je donnais ces mêmes boîtes aux petits chats,
(Rires)
puis je leur ai donné du poulet et du riz que nous avions préparés
et ils ont préféré le poulet et le riz.
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Même eux ne mangent pas ça.
On peut nourrir l'humanité pour un jour ou deux, ou cinq,
mais ces rations coûtent 12, 14, 15, 20 dollars aux contribuables américains.
Ça convient pour un petit moment,
pendant une bataille,
mais pas pour nourrir des Américains pendant des semaines entières,
alors qu'on pourrait recruter la communauté d'affaires locale
pour faire le même travail, mais mieux ; créer des emplois localement,
aider l'économie locale à se remettre sur pied,
et simultanément, s'assurer que tout va s'arranger
et redevenir normal le plus rapidement possible.
C'est là que nous avons commencé à cuisiner.
Tu étais avec moi,
c'est là qu'on a utilisé tout l'argent disponible sur nos cartes de crédit.
Si AMEX écoute cette présentation, un petit rabais serait apprécié.
(Rires)
Visa aussi.
NM : Quelle est la situation aujourd'hui ?
C'était il y a un mois.
Tu as dit que la situation s'est améliorée à San Juan,
et que tu te concentres sur la campagne.
Mais il reste sans aucun doute des défis majeurs. C'est quoi la suite ?
JA : La suite, c'est que nous allons progressivement nous retirer,
après que FEMA nous ait plus ou moins fait comprendre
qu'ils pensaient avoir tout sous contrôle,
et que nos services n'étaient plus nécessaires,
mais bon, on ne les croit pas vraiment.
Nous avons quitté le stade, 60 000 repas par jour,
pour emménager dans un autre espace, aussi grand, mais localisé stratégiquement
et moins cher.
Là, on va préparer 20 à 25 000 repas par jour.
Ensuite, on va laisser quatre, cinq ou six cuisines
dans des endroits stratégiques de l'île,
loin dans les montagnes, dans les régions pauvres.
On a beaucoup de données.
Nous savons qui utilise l'assistance alimentaire, des coupons,
des cartes.
Nous savons qui les possède et qui les utilise.
Dans les zones de l'île où personne ne les utilise,
c'est là que nous allons concentrer nos efforts.
C'est incroyable comme de simples données peuvent fournir des indices
sur les gens dans le besoin.
Nous nous sommes rendus dans une petite ville appelée Morovis.
Très belle.
La meilleure rôtisserie dans l'histoire de l'humanité.
Vous devriez visiter Morovis.
DT : C'est une bonne idée.
JA : On avait des sandwichs.
Mais avec les gens de la sécurité nationale, on s'y est arrêté
et on y a mangé du poulet rôti.
J'ai apporté les sandwichs dans une autre ville, San Lorenzo.
La situation y était critique car le pont était détruit.
C'était une île dans l'île,
une petite communauté entourée par l'eau.
Tout le monde nous parlait du désastre là-bas.
On a apporté les sandwichs.
Mais sur le retour vers Morovis,
j'ai pensé que si c'est une catastrophe, les sandwichs ne suffiront pas.
J'ai apporté 120 poulets, avec du yucca et du riz,
et une fois arrivés au pont détruit,
on a traversé le fleuve.
Il y avait de l'eau partout.
Mais nous avons apporté les 120 poulets,
et la nourriture.
La communauté nous a remerciés puis nous a dit ceci :
« Ça va aller. Nous n'avons plus besoin de nourriture.
On a le gaz, de l'argent,
de la nourriture et notre eau est pure.
Aidez les autres communautés qui en ont plus besoin. »
La communication est la clé.
Dans ces scénarios, on peut soit se baser sur des données erronées,
soit obtenir les bonnes informations pour prendre des décisions intelligentes
et vraiment s'occuper des vrais problèmes.
C'est ce que nous faisons.
(Applaudissements)
NM : C'est une opération incroyable,
et la chance de pouvoir l'observer, d'y contribuer un tout petit peu --
JA : Tu l'as lancée.
NM : Au moment le plus intense, vous prépariez 150 000 repas
par jour, dans toute l'île.
C'est incroyable.
Je crois que vous avez aussi mis sur pied un modèle
pour réaliser cela ; espérons qu'il sera utile dans l'avenir.
C'est une des grandes leçons de cette histoire --
DT : C'est possible. On peut répliquer cela.
JA : Mais je ne vais plus regarder TED,
car vous avez cette conviction que tout est possible.
(Rires)
Ma femme m'a dit ceci :
« Tu m'as dit que tu allais cuisiner 1 000 repas par jour.
Je ne peux pas te laisser seul, même pour une journée ! »
(Rires)
J'espère que World Central Kitchen --
il y a une chose que j'ai omis de dire :
j'ai pris mon téléphone et j'ai contacté plein de gens
qui avaient selon moi une expertise utile pour nous.
J'ai donc téléphoné à une entreprise appelée Bon Appétit, à Fedele.
C'est l'une des grandes entreprises de service traiteur.
Ils travaillent pour Google et les grands stades.
Ils viennent de Californie
et appartiennent à un groupe plus grand, Compass.
Je leur ai dit ceci :
« J'ai besoin de cuisiniers, de cuisiniers capables de faire du volume,
mais du volume bon et de qualité. »
En moins de 24 heures, j'ai commencé à réunir les gens et les chefs.
À un moment, nous avions les 16 meilleurs chefs d'Amérique.
L'Amérique est un pays avec un cœur extraordinaire,
qui envoie toujours ses meilleurs éléments.
Ce que nous avons appris avec les années,
c'est que ces chefs américains vont jouer un rôle dans la manière
avec laquelle on nourrit l'Amérique, et peut-être d'autres parties du monde,
dans les situations d'urgence.
Ce que nous devons lancer,
c'est l'apport d'expertise adéquate là où elle est nécessaire.
Parfois j'ai le sentiment, comme avec FEMA,
qu'on rassemble la mauvaise expertise là où elle n'est même pas nécessaire.
Les gens de FEMA sont des gens fabuleux.
Des hommes et des femmes intelligents et préparés,
mais sous une incroyable arborescence organisationnelle hiérarchique en pyramide
où tout le monde est écrasé par le poids de la hiérarchie.
Il convient d'émanciper les gens pour atteindre le succès.
Nous avons une organisation plus aplatie,
où chaque personne s'approprie la situation,
et prend des décisions pour résoudre les problèmes quand ils surgissent.
(Applaudissements)
DT : Exactement.
Applaudissez encore une fois José Andrés.
(Applaudissements) (Encouragements)